I,
um,
I want you to ponder
over the next few days,
uh,
what is commemorated
on October 7th,
the next October 7th,
which will be next Wednesday.
Get bonus points for your midterm.
If you, if you know it right off the
top of your head already, you can, uh,
you can tell me if not, think about
it and, uh, you may come up with it.
There's something very relevant
to this, uh, course and, uh,
I can see that my tas,
the graduate students
are also puzzled by it.
Uh, you can, you can go
home and Google it and, uh,
and maybe it'll come up, but, uh, um,
we'll talk about it on Tuesday,
which would be the eve of the
anniversary of you was okay.
Um,
we are going to talk today,
uh, uh, mostly,
but not exclusively about the novel
of the curious impertinent as you can
anticipate by the various triangles on,
uh,
on the board.
Um,
said Avantis was criticized in his time
for the inclusion of this novel in part
one of the key halting.
He answered,
he answered his critics through.
He's characters who speak
about that criticism. Uh,
chiefly a character,
a character called Sung,
Sung Carrasco whom you will meet,
uh,
when you begin reading part
two very soon. And, uh,
he also talks about it in
the prologue to part two,
and, uh, he said Advantis refrained
from inserting any novels
like this in part two.
So, uh, he took the criticism to heart.
Um,
as I said in my last lecture,
Cervantes was trying to
combine the sequential kind
of plot of that you Valerie
romance one adventure after another,
uh,
with the collection of stories
in the style of Boccaccio a book.
Got Joe. I have him I
think before, but uh,
if not,
uh,
okay.
But Capture Giovanni Boccaccio 13, 13, 13,
1375. If you're a literature
major, you should know,
uh, Boccaccio or to know at least
about Boccaccio culture. He's,
uh, his work, his famous
work is called the camera on
now. Not that, that evaluate romances, uh,
didn't have convoluted plots,
but the insertion of a novel like
this was not one of its features.
It is known.
That said,
Avantis contemplated the publication
of a collection of stories to be called
Semanas.
They'll haredim weeks at the
garden and he did publish in 16,
13,
the collection of stories that you have
and from which you will read called the
exemplary novels, no
way less, uh, him Pladis
this collection,
as you will discover,
does not have an overarching fiction
involving character narrators leaving the
city fleeing the plague and
gathering to tell stories as in the,
the camera on the overarching fiction
into the camera on is that all of these
young people leave the city because there
is a plague they gather in a pleasant
place and they each tell
a story every day. And uh,
that is the overarching fiction of the,
the camera on the exemplaries
novels of Cervantes did,
does not have such an overarching fiction
is just a collection of stories by
Miguel. Listen, run tests
with a prologue and so forth,
uh,
weeks in the garden or [inaudible] does
sound as it would have had that kind of
applaud meaning overarching plot,
meaning that characters would
get together in a garden until,
uh,
stories.
The point is that in, in, uh, India,
Quixote part one,
uh,
Cervantes is attempting to mesh these
two forms of narrative. As I said,
uh,
the result may seem awkward,
but it is mostly really very innovative
and it leads to the creation of the
modern novel with this
very loose structure,
which this kind of in Thurston is,
uh,
is possible.
Now we saw how those commingling stories
about Fernando [inaudible] and Lucinda,
uh,
hallow stories are correlated.
And my colleague from the Department
of Comparative Literature,
David Quint calls it interlacing
how the stories are interconnected.
In a fairly recent book on Sarah on this.
And I proposed that their structure,
the overall structure,
all of these stories with his cuts,
faults and gaps was like a
representation of human memory,
human memory of bunk,
which fiction depends and on which the
very makeup of the creative self of the
author is based memory.
As we will see, uh, today
and in the next class,
uh,
the final resolution of the conflicts
in those stories is a narrative to the
force,
the very devil boast of artistry
on the part of Savantas.
But the novel of the curious impertinent
does stick out as being very different
and apparently only tenuously related to
the main plot and to the other stories
from twitch differs.
Why is the story inserted
here in the whole day?
You could say, is it, is it padding,
it's Amanda's patting his novel
or does it have something to do with the
intercalated stories that we have been
discussing and that are
about to be resolved?
First,
let us go over how Cervantes does
justify the inclusion of the novel.
At the most elementary level.
The innkeeper one Palmetto
reveals that he keeps a suitcase.
Somebody left with some papers and
that he owns a number of chief Valerie
Romances.
This is a second suitcase we find the
first was kind of which the character's
found rotted in the middle of the
Seattle La Morena and it also contained
writing contained gardenias manuscripts
and poems and some shirts and most
importantly for sanctuary.
So money
and discussion ensues
involving the innkeeper,
his wife and daughter and under priest
about the value of those books that you
Valerie Romances.
This is a return to the scrutiny
of the books episode earlier.
Hm.
Um, the scrutiny of the books,
in fact, it's mentioned by
the, uh, by the characters.
The breeze wants to burn that
you've all read romances. I see.
Did we don Quixote's but the innkeeper,
we'll have none of it.
One Paloma, as he says, he's
not mad. He's not insane.
He knows that what those books
relate happened a long time ago.
Not In the present as don Quixote does.
He knows that it is not applicable
to the present in a day.
In addition,
he maintains the romances of jewelry,
provide entertainment.
When at harvest time the workers gather
around at the end of the day and someone
reads out loud from one of them.
The tradition of reading out loud goes
back to the middle ages and the convents
and monasteries and a n and rituals
of, of, of, of, of, of that,
uh, uh, kind in an in such institutions.
MMM.
He says that it provides a soulless
and on rest and relaxation.
At the end of of of work,
the ink keeper's wife and daughter,
uh,
for their part are fond of the,
of the love scenes and
they talk particularly the
daughter about the love scenes
that move her so much.
Uh,
one Palo Banca defense,
the voracity of the chivalric romances
saying that these books are published
with the approval of the crowns councils
have the stamp of the Crown Council.
How could the crown allow
books of lies to be published?
Of course he has a very primitive
notion about printed books and,
and, and so forth. He
is corrected by others,
the priests mostly,
but to no avail.
He still sticks to his guns,
but no books are birthed
because books are not Bert.
They will be soon another scene with a
character who is the Canon of Toledo.
You will learn what the Canon of polio
or what it can on is when we get to that
part in which the romances of
chivalry will again be discussed,
uh, but at a theoretical level, uh,
by,
by very well educated and well
read characters like the priests,
the Kingdom of [inaudible] and Don
Quixote and so forth. But here,
Savannah seems to be emphasizing that
the romances of chilvery do have a
function in society.
They Fernie's relaxation Buhler people.
It is foolish to take Cervantes at his
word when he says that he has written the
Quixote to demolish and
banish romances of jewelry.
There are people who still
take him at face value on that,
but in fact,
the Quixote as we go parodies
is both a critique on an Amish,
the romances of chivalry,
and it is perhaps the last
of the romances of chivalry.
So, uh, uh, oh, we must
not take, I don't think so.
Run this seriously when he says
that he wrote the book simply to,
to do away with the romances of children.
Remember what I've,
what I said before that by his time
essentially the fashion, uh, uh,
uh, of publishing them
anyway, uh, had ended,
but they continue to be read at
least if we take the Quixote, uh, uh,
evidence of, uh, of there being
read by the common people.
Now,
then the innkeeper speaks about the
papers in the suitcase and main choose the
story,
the novel of the curious impertinent,
which he says had been approvingly
red in it had also been read out loud
at the inn.
It is in manuscript form much
literature including Cervantes,
his own stories,
uh,
still circulated in manuscript even after
the development of the printing press.
A sprinting was complicated and expensive.
So you must not assume that
once printing became available,
literature did not circulate in
manuscript form anymore. It did.
And, uh, some of, uh, uh,
set of anthesis work, uh,
segregated in that in such fashion.
Some of the stories that were later
included in the exemplary novels,
a book had been circulating in,
in this form.
This is then another self
referential moment in the 80s.
To me clear.
That's advantage.
It is a himself who left
that suitcase there with the,
with the manuscript instead of anthis
is again winking at the reader.
And this is me who left
this suitcase here.
Ah,
it is clear too that he has found a way
to publish the story by inserting it
here in the Quixote. Uh, that doesn't
mean that it just padding the novel,
uh,
the long short story,
the novella or move well in the manner of,
uh,
Boccaccio was a form with which Cervantes
felt very comfortable as you will
discover what you read the stories.
And as you have already discovered
in this integrated stories that he,
this sort of long short story is
a form that's Advantis a favorite.
Now
let us not miss the irony, which is
easy to miss. We have to read carefully.
Remember, read for
details. That is the, the,
the irony that it is the
priest who reads out loud,
the novel of the, uh,
curious, impertinent,
this perverse twist.
The love story is told in the voice
over representative of the church.
This priest is a very,
um,
a complicated character
as you were just covering.
He invents Duvall with
Romances, uh, and uh,
he's uh, uh, uh, out in the fields
such as using a don Quixote.
And, uh, uh, it is, uh,
do me a very ironic that you have the
priest reading this, uh, uh, this story,
Cervantes loaves, this, uh, ironic games.
It is the priest who at the end those
a critique of the story and asked
permission to have it copied
later Cervantes. This is
engaging here in some, some,
some self criticism but also in some
self praise having one of his characters
praise the story with some reservation,
but the prisons it this breeze just
as we have already learned this also
literary critic I've rediscovered in the
episode of the scrutiny of the books.
No,
the novel of the curious in pregnant
is the most blatantly literary story
contained in the whole day,
the most artful and obviously
derived from literary sources.
The action is set in Florence
and in a vaguely defined past.
It is a time and place of fictions,
not depressant, uh, uh, in which, uh,
the Quixote takes place.
It is drawn from a known Italian sources
and written in the style of Walcott Geo
whom you now know and Ben law
bail bundle.
This course is under the ages of the
literature major that is comparative
literature. So you are getting quite
a bit of Italian literature here,
which is inevitable.
Uh,
Mateo been below 1485,
1561 who was one of the great short,
short story writers already
of the 16th Century, uh, uh,
much red throughout Europe. And in
fact, one of his stories inspired,
uh, Romeo and Juliet.
Shakespeare as you know,
was very fond of reading
Italian literature.
In fact,
the novel of the curious impertinent,
essentially drawn from audio stores.
Orlando Furioso.
I have mentioned Ariosto several times,
but I will mention him again now.
Okay.
His famous poem is Orlando
for yours or [inaudible] 1474,
1533. And the Orlando of food,
he also was published in 15,
16 then 15,
21 and 1532.
It is a mock epic as I've
mentioned before. Uh, uh,
it's a mock epic poem that's
Advantis much admired and,
uh, as we should know by now. So we
have here these three Italian authors,
uh, that, uh, that Avantis, uh,
was indebted to. Um, other, uh,
more distant sources have been found.
But Ariosto is the abuse one
when very distant source,
uh,
of the story of a king who wanted
to put his wife to the test and,
and had somebody seduce her and so forth.
The same story,
but that is very remote. And, uh, uh,
the most obvious source
is a fragment from, uh,
the Orlando Foodie.
Also, I underscore again,
a set of anthesis indebtedness to it
through the two Italian Renaissance
Literature,
uh,
as he was also two Italian
renaissance art. As I mentioned in my,
in my last lecture.
Remember,
you have been reading the case book
and your introduction in Toronto.
I spent a good deal of time in Italy,
which had been of course the center
of the, of the, of the renaissance.
Now, the novel of the curious impertinent
has been variously interpreted,
but the most apt analysis the most,
uh,
how could I say, um, a
current or, uh, analysis, uh,
the most accepted is the one by her ne
Jeeva as you are now we have a French,
no.
Do you allow was a French professor who
taught in the United States nearly all
of his life.
His most famous book was called in the
original most songs romantic very day.
It romanesco known in English as deceit,
desire, and the novel, the original,
the first publication was 1961.
Your asshole theory revolves around the
concept of triangular or mimetic desire.
This desire is both external,
what it applies to a novel
and it's sources, the,
the previous books that it imitates
and internal when it applies to the
protagonists, love relations.
And in fact you are,
will claim that all novels
contained the current level.
Knowles is this kind of memetic triangular
desire and his book contains analysis
of famous novels in
the European tradition,
like madame Bovary who shall in
wild and so forth. I recommend,
uh,
his book.
Now the story of I should run this.
Then all of the curious impertinent is
crucial to the development of Gerard's
theory and indeed it made having spired.
His theory is that important.
Gerard rights and this is,
I know it's a little dense quotation
translated from French into a little
awkward English. I'll read it very
slowly. Uh, so that you can follow it.
He says the existence of the novel of
the curious impertinent in the key Hartej
cause always intrigued critics.
The question arises whether the short
story is compatible with the novel.
The unity of the masterpiece
seems somewhat compromised.
It is this unity which I revealed by our
journey through novelistic literature,
his journey in the book through novelistic
literature in which he shows her this
triangular desire exists in all its not
having begun with sort of Antici begins
his book.
We serantes we returned to Cervantes
and ascertain that this novelists genius
has grasped the extreme forms of imitated
desire nor small distance separates
this advantage of donkey, haughty
and disadvantages of Ansel motions.
All the novels we have considered in this
chapter as they show that the distance
is not in Superbowl. Since all the
novelists are linked to each other.
The simultaneous presence of external
and internal mediation in the same work
seems to us to confirm the unity of
novelistic literature and in turn,
the unity of this literature
confirms dot of [inaudible].
One is proved by the other,
just as one proves that the earth
is round by going around it.
The creative force of Cervantes is so
great that it has exerted effortlessly
that he has been exerted effortlessly
throughout the whole novelistic space.
All the ideas of the western novel
are precedent in German Don Quixote.
I keep, I continue reading Gerard
and the idea of these ideas,
the idea who central role is
constantly being confirmed.
The basic idea from which
one can rediscover everything
is triangular desire.
That's the end of the court.
I am sure this sounds very
strange and obscure to you. Uh,
if you haven't heard about it before,
but I tell you, once you understand it,
you may glean something
useful about your love life.
I said that reading the Quixote
would provide lessons for living.
When I was a graduate student,
this book was the rage and everyone
was interpreting his or her love
relationships in terms
of triangular desire.
Um,
so you don't have to make any
confessions at the end of the course,
but you might, uh, uh, uh, if you want to
tell me if this has helped you in any way,
understand your life.
Okay.
For Gerard,
desire is never spontaneous.
It's never a spontaneous
one to one relationship,
but mediated one desires a man or woman
because he or she is desired by another.
It is dark,
presume desire by the mediator
that makes her or him attractive.
I say presume because then the
mediators desire most yet have another,
a mediator to exist as such.
And then there will be a sort of
an endless series of mediations,
but we are focusing on
one triangle at a time.
Jealousy,
in other words,
is a requirement for desire for love.
You can now think of all the novels you
have reading with jealousy plays such an
important role.
Post full of jealous characters.
Okay.
Hence imitation of the mediator,
the one of whom one is jealous is of the
essence because of the belief that she
or he is loved by the object of
our desire. If you followed done,
this is the mimetic part of
desire, which may lead to the, uh,
to desire for the mediator in the guise
of desire for the original object of
desire.
That is you love so much the mediator
that you wind up loving the mediator,
not loving the person that you began.
You thought you began to love it.
You will see some of that in the novel,
the curious impertinent
in the context of the novel of the
cooters. In pertinent, it works like this.
We begin here. Um, you
have, uh, your, uh, uh,
your handout for easy reference.
Uh,
Anselmo cannot love really Kamila
until he gets low Tario to love her.
This is the gist of this
man's twist desire that,
uh, and, and, and why he
must put her to the test.
So, and sell more loves Camilla, but once,
but loteria is inserted as the mediator.
Then eventually when
Notario loves Camilla,
uh,
he does.
So in second triangle because
she has loved Anselmo before.
So we have these two triangles,
uh,
now this story may will reveal
a hidden sub story of the kind.
Uh, we, uh,
have been finding when characters tell
stories and the story may very well be
and it has been, uh, um, uh,
proposed a homosexual love between the
two friends using Camila as the mediator,
the certain, the third
triangle and sell more, uh,
really loves little patio, uh,
using Camilla ask the mediator.
And last way,
Gomez way w e y Nicole,
last way,
Gomes has written a very rare
swift persuasive article,
not only about that relationship between
the two, but also showing that Ansel,
most illnesses,
uh,
both physical or psychosomatic,
are feminine in the Medicine of the time,
uh,
to underscore the nature of the
relationship between these two.
So I hope that you're
understanding all of this and uh,
I hope it's not ruining your
love life, uh, uh, and uh,
uh, or your life in general by
realizing how complicated love can be.
Now,
this structure sheds light on the
intertwined stories that we have been
discussing. And this is why I have, uh,
these, uh, other triangles here on
the, on the board, on, on your handout.
Uh, uh, whereas, uh,
where we have that, uh,
this Fernando,
uh,
Gardenia Lucinda Triangle
in which Fernando loves
Lucinda really because she is
Cardenas a girl, uh, or it's going
to be his, his girl eventually,
and I suggested this in another
class. There is also, uh, there are,
there are intimations of a homoerotic
relationship here between Fernando on
Cardinia.
Now for the non goal when
it comes to the [inaudible],
Fernando loses interest in Doterra once
he has processed her because there is no
mediation.
But he marries her once.
She appears at the end defended by Carl
venue. So once got a Daniel appears,
I said potential, uh, uh, mediator, uh,
Fernando, uh, goes ahead
and Mary's the pair.
Now a
donkey halters mediations,
other romances of chivalry and his heroes,
particularly the [inaudible], the
governor whom he imitates. I see.
You also imitates Orlando,
the Orlando also the
object of his love to see.
Now I said projection of the
loves of those famous lovers.
Oriana in the case of where Mardis
Angelica and the case of Orlando,
which is why he desires her and in the
way inventor from their own constructions
of her. And uh, we will
see her transformation,
uh, as the novel progresses,
which are a remarkable,
especially in part two.
Now,
the novel of the curious impertinent
is that holds up a mirror,
the mirror of literature to the young
people involved in love stories that are
about to culminate in marriage.
It provides a contrast to the comedy
like ending of the stories of Fernando,
Little Gardenia and Lucinda.
The novel of the curious in pertinent is
not so much an admonition though it is
that to us a lesson about the
complexities of love and how no permanent
stability can be achieved,
particularly not by marriage.
It is also a wink at the reader.
I think a wake up call, I mean,
can anyone,
you will see one who does soon,
but can anyone really believe in the
sincerity and the sincerity of the
permanence of don't Fernando's conversion?
Is it likely that Fernando
will be a faithful husband?
What about Lucinda?
She was tempted ones by money
and status and could be again,
literature teachers through pleasure,
a very harsh lesson.
Ultimately the novel of the
curious impertinent is about,
in my view,
the death instinct,
concealed within desire co evil with it,
with love.
It is what Freud called the death drive.
There is no stability where there is
desire that their affection of a social
erotic situation of Anselmo,
Camilla and Lotoja.
We Send me Raj and an
invitation to tragedy.
This is an even harsher lesson
about the human condition.
What the priest says at the end is that
he finds that the story well written but
he cannot believe, uh, that
the author has not, uh,
has not shown a real situation because
her husband would never do that.
Uh, that maybe young people, uh,
in love before marriage, um, uh,
ward but not husband.
What he's saying they are is something
that is a given in old golden age,
Spanish literature and they're given
is that everything that happens before
marriage is the stuff of
comedy and everything that
happens after marriage is to
stuff of tragedy.
This is not a lesson to be
taken too seriously,
but it's something to be a pondered.
Um, and I think that this
is what the priest notices.
He notices that, that this, this to
him would not be possible for a, uh,
uh, a husband to, to, to do this, uh,
subject his wife to this sort of,
of tests.
But then if it were among
people not married yet,
it may in May we made me,
of course a
marriage is usually
the ending of a comedy.
Comedy's tend to end in marriage because
marriage is a return to stability.
And in, in, in theater, uh,
comedy is a return to an
order that has been upset
where our strategy does
not return, uh, to order.
So this is what the literary side of that,
uh,
would be whether it is
applicable or not to life.
It is for everyone, each one
of us to, uh, to discover.
So now we move to the ending of
all of these stories are the,
uh,
[inaudible].
Fernando accepts Dorothea after everyone
pleads with him and a good deal of
services about the concept of
[inaudible] from [inaudible].
She pleads her case, uh, with us.
March verbus Marcella did in an
earlier episode and with a very,
um, thorough knowledge
of Castilian, uh, law.
MMM.
You see, she is lacking
either via Dorothea nobility,
but it Albia is passed on through
the male line, not the female line.
As we've mentioned here before, this is
what she underscores in her own defense.
Uh,
[inaudible] house.
He's Lucinda who has the either
but not the wealth Dorothea has.
Um,
so there is,
I mentioned in the earlier crass
sort of crisscrossing here,
a mirror image of the,
of the two women, uh,
that is, uh, has no, uh,
nobility but has money and
Lucinda has very little money,
but she has a nobility and so
forth. Lucinda, by the way,
in the midst of all this had been
kidnapped from a convent. Uh,
I'm brought to the in, in what, in
what turns out to be a side story,
not told in detail.
These stories could be,
could be extended. I didn't feed item
if you pursued every one of them,
but remember seen the, uh,
had been kidnapped and she's,
she's brought back for this, uh, ending.
Have you heard of red or whom
I mentioned in the last class,
and I mentioned him here
again with the respect and uh,
sometimes we'll disagree
with good old Javier who is
very, was retired now,
very competent critic.
Uh,
and uh,
also I should say a very
catholic Craig as you will read,
as you would understand from what I read
here, that's, there's no sin in that.
Uh,
have you had eto interprets in this way?
The Battle of the Wineskins, uh, that
leads to the resolution of the conflict.
He also has a kind of symbolic sexual
symbolic interpretation of the whole
thing, but it's good to
hear it, uh, to, uh, to, uh,
corrected a little bit,
but learn from it.
He says the meaning of the battle
against the wineskins is now clear.
He has been exposed.
You're leading.
Don Quixote is in a state of the nation
since he's really possessed by an
intense dream and acting with closed eyes.
Thanks to super impose wineskins which
he saw in his room when he went to bed to
be the giant panda
Filando and to behead him,
he cuts the head around
and pierces the body.
The wine flow floods the room
on fills the end with smell.
Don Quixote has destroyed an erect
penis. This is what good. All right.
Um,
has filled in with the smell of wine.
Donkey hot the has certainly
cut down the power of lost.
I'm still putting this
blood transform into wine.
Most certainly be taken
as a sacramental symbol,
a symbol of the mysterious power of the
night against the anaerobes, pestilence,
metaphorically. The courage and
courtesy of Don Quixote have a vanquish.
The arrogance, cruelty,
and lost of Don Fernando.
It is true of donkey halter is wrong.
That is,
adventures have created havoc and morally,
his motivation is mixed,
but it is also an undeniable that
he's courageous, truthful, and chased.
His foolishness brings
him blows and ridicule,
but his greatness makes him a worth.
The instrument of providence
and rental goes on.
We see clearly that the spiritual move
movement has been completed by don't.
Fernando's descend from lost and pride
to a Christian humility and fraternity,
but which he races his victims to the
level of his affection and now reunited in
love.
A common embraces possible.
The giant is dead and the true man,
the Christian gentleman has replaced him,
but which powers have brought
about the conversion has,
has it been the beauty that tears
the truths of Dorothea the priests or
situation?
They certainly all have a part in it,
but the texts leaves no doubt
that all these elements together,
together we're talking [inaudible] have
been the instruments of providence with
a capital p while men and women,
he goes on,
I'd been acting through the
impulse of their passions,
which brought them to the
labyrinth of the Sierra Morina.
Not a reference has been made by say
wanted to Savantas to heavens will,
but as soon as Cardenio meets
Doterra and installed at Don,
Fernando did not take
Lucy [inaudible] with him.
He expresses hope that heaven has decreed
their salvation from that moment on
their destinies began to escape from the
darkness and confusion of the elaborate
at the end,
the locals of social reunion.
And consequently of the transition
from wildness to civilization.
Lucinda having been released
by Don Fernando in the scene,
justice gripe exclaims his clothing,
Lucinda observe how heaven by unusual
and to us hidden ways has brought me into
the presence of my true husband and well,
you know,
buy a thousand Dearborn
experiences that death alone.
Can you face him out of my memory
goes on immediately.
And in the long scene of reconciliation,
all the participants claim that they're
meeting in the end is not accidental,
but on the contrary, the work
of provenance, of course,
the question to be considered is the
conflicts would have been solved without
the intervention of Gnocchi. Chaotic.
Uh, which I will speak about in a minute.
I think that, uh, that he was the
agent of course. Uh, in any case,
a little winds up his article,
uh,
which ultimately deals with
the whole issue of marriage,
which is so important and they can halt.
And so important in the 16th
century and about whom, uh,
the likes of Erasmus on Bvs
wrote as he quotes them. And,
and the Council of Trent, which is taking
place as you know, from reading, uh,
earlier, uh, discussed that.
We will talk about this again in part
when we talk about part two about
marriages and all of that because he
hasn't said marriages are the core of
social stability and social, uh, on
transitions in, in, in, in, in, in,
in society. The way that society, uh,
renews itself. So it's,
it's, it's crucial.
So this is what a retro rights and it's
important because he is bringing in
first the,
the neoplatonic notion of notions of
love derived from the courtly love
tradition that I think I've spoken about,
uh,
against a sort of a movement in Spanish
society and in 16th Century Society and
philosophy in general to
two or more bourgeois, uh,
sense of marriage. Uh, uh, you remember,
I think I've spoken about the Courtney
love tradition according to of tradition,
which is one of the great,
uh, uh, uh, uh, can I say, uh,
uh,
spiritual revolutions in the West is the,
the idea that the woman, uh,
had to be adored at a distance.
The law love could not be consummated.
It usually the love [inaudible]
a woman who was unattainable,
preferably married and, uh, the lower
paid homage to the woman and so forth.
Uh, we still hear the
echoes of the, of the,
of the courtroom off tradition
in modern poetry, in Ooda,
on Octavio Paz and the great
modern, uh, points. Uh,
Doki hotter is a courtly
lover in that sense, an agent,
uh, out of fashion, a
Courtney lover. But that's,
that is what inspires a,
his love for Lucy. Now,
neoplatonism of course, was at
the core of these, uh, uh, uh,
uh, Courtney love traditionalist. Okay.
So [inaudible] says the following.
Now that I think I have placed this in
the in its ideological context against a
sentimental and neoplatonic tradition
which made a woman a goddess,
Cervantes takes the side of the conjugal
love presented by Erasmus and Vvs
Erasmus of Rotterdam. I will speak
more about him following classes.
It was a very important
16th century humanist
and so what's Bibi's
which allows my not only do enjoy the
legitimate pleasure of the sexual union,
but to help each other to fight against
the inevitable weakness and imperfection
of the human condition.
By emphasizing the social
civilizing aspects of marriage,
Cervantes was closer to the new doctrines
of reform then to the renaissance
ideals of love. Indeed with he
said he's thinking of patriarch,
got to see last two on the ports
that I have mentioned before.
Indeed with his attacks on the pastoral
and by the story of El Kudos in
pertinent to the curio.
Then all of curation pertinent Cervantes
is precisely marking his distance from
the Gregory Socratic tradition of the
renaissance and joining the new to a great
extent,
Bourgeois Christianity,
which descended to the south of Europe
from the low countries in opposition to
[inaudible] marine billionaires.
These are the that you heroes so that
you've all read romances. The Nouveau,
you are a lover. It's not a
knife, but a Christian gentlemen,
such love as we have
seen has two elements.
It is Christian and the
activity of providence and
the priest show the role that
God and his church play in, in its
growth, but it's also jumped in mentally.
Both got Denny on. Don't Fernando become
through love, not only Christians,
but Christian gentlemen. Core three
love brings the night to madness,
but Christian Love saves him.
Such a rescue is metaphorically expressed
in our story by the great classical
myth of the labyrinth lost in the
wilderness of this, yet at the Morena,
their lives twisted into the integrate
mace of the librarians on the brink of
being devoured by the mentor
of lost the madness. Cardinia,
Lucinda Rotarian Fernando are finally
rescued by don't keyholders courageous
battle and bear the civilizing
force of an Erasmian church.
Divine providence in fact,
has provided us a Rodney the saving.
So that that's the end of her,
of the court,
which I hope now you can understand given
the background that I gave you about
all of these sounds fine.
And it is instructive,
particularly the references to
harass me most and to beers, uh,
until we take into account the hilarious
convolutions and the mixture of madness,
dreams and lies that bring about
the resolution of the conflict.
The conflict has been solved by
don't get hold this intervention.
Uh,
but how can such a ridiculous figure and
be the instrument of providence with a
capital p?
They have been solved by donkey health,
this agency because they are truly
worldly conflicts involving tensions of a
world in social flux where the older
values to say the values of the,
uh, of the, of the, uh, the renaissance,
the values of quarterly love,
uh, no longer hold sway,
don't get halted and bodies the mixture
of values in transition so he can
mediate in the various
conflicts and solve them.
He would not have been able to do
so if we had been a real night,
nor had he been an ordinary man
of his time. But to say this,
it's not to do justice to the multilayer
plots on raveling in these episodes.
I am mostly struck by sort of
anthis inventiveness by the wild.
You're disciplined imagination at play,
which cannot I think be reduced to
this a providential a scheme that,
that, that have you had, uh, offers don't,
Fernando is the one level
[inaudible] the giant,
remember the rhyme, fair to
Nando, bong, Daffy Langdon,
the figure of fun.
Now,
Philando though invented at Hawk by
the priest is presented as an effective
factor in the outcome of the conflicts
are denied the Weiss and Princess
[inaudible] Macona although
not real and grotesque
don't real in relation to
the fiction of the normal.
This whole ensemble exists and performs
on a level not unlike that of the
characters who invented them or who
invented this whole ensemble ensemble.
There story of Panda Filando
is like a dream version,
a recognizable distortion
of Doterra's real conflict.
If you remember when we went over it,
the story of the story of Panda
Filando is like a dream version. Uh,
uh, I, I repeat, uh, off of
total territorial conflict.
Remember again,
the hidden meaning of Mikko Macona over
which I will go again if her name that
is an illusion to mimicry
to representation. To me,
Macy's do the very process
by which she was invented.
Those Mikami Kona not in a way
represent representation itself.
I mean she is the representation
itself taking place before our eyes
are all these inventions of characters
by other characters similar to Cervantes
invention of his own
characters in the hotel.
And this is what this
whole thing is telling us.
This is what is truly Dennis sling,
about the resolution of all
these conflicts that they
do unravel at every level.
Sort of simultaneously that is
to say, and this is, uh, the, uh,
what you have on the back of
your triangles. And I have
here on the, on the, on,
on the board, uh, the all these
levels, the donkey holders dream,
which is ducky holdup on the Philando.
And we can we go now, he caught the,
the head off of the giant.
He thinks in the dream they met a
fictional creation by the priest.
That story the priest invents and
Amico Macona then, uh, performs,
uh, meaning Dorothea Doki,
Hotifa, Philando becoming,
going up in actually all
these characters in that,
in that novel that the priest
and, and, and Dorothea invent.
And then there is the fiction of the
novel, which is Donkey Horton on Fernando,
a little terror and so forth.
All of those levels sort of
collapse together and are,
the conflicts are resolved by Don Quixote,
uh,
slaying the slang,
the,
the giant that is occurring,
uh,
bursting poor.
One Paloma is wine skins to his horror.
Um,
it is a stroke of genius that the process
of restitution will be motivated by
Don Quixote's nightmare,
which comes to interrupt the reading of
the novel of the curious in pregnant or
the point incidentally near the end,
which is when it's about to unravel.
When that Novelis about doing robbed,
another case of these interruptions
in the dream don't be healthy.
Completes the story of
Princess Mikami Corner.
That is Doterra's predicament translated
into the language of chivalry.
Like Don Quixote psychotic
delusion. Remember about, uh,
uh, uh, about, uh, uh,
queen Massima having had an affair
with this surgeon, uh, which was, uh,
his version of Lucinda in the
flower by the Fernando. Um,
now these version of the testing
Burgerville true to the name,
she assumes it's a grotesque parody of
her story. I go back to what you said.
Remember that Mikko Means Monkey Mikami
colonize the twice monkey with an
argumentative like that.
Remember the [inaudible] that I mentioned,
Segundo Second Dome from second.
Second Dong is a big second,
uh, grand too. Delong in Spanish, uh,
low marks for alarm marks and so forth.
Mikko me come is, it is an augmented
if involved there McCormick.
Uh, remember monkey see monkey do
and all of that. It's in the back.
She said big blown up. Distorted copy
of [inaudible]. This is what Mikko.
Mikko Nice.
The ending of [inaudible] story in that
register is what breaks off the reading.
As I mentioned of the novel
of the curious. In pertinent,
that story will be resumed and
comes to it's very tragic ending.
While those of Cardenio Leucine,
that latte under Fernando,
we'll have it purely
comic one happy endings,
as I mentioned with marriages
are typical of the, of comedy.
This is yet another intersection of
the two stories here with the accent on
section and crossing on cutting.
The ending of the novel of the curious
in pertinent reveals his artificial
literary quality when the reading is
concluded. And as I've mentioned that the,
the, the priest, uh, uh, uh, uh, remarks,
uh, uh, as I said that it doesn't sound,
it doesn't sound right for a husband to
have done some that it's not good me,
Macy's.
Uh,
and then there follow the court
like scene of reconciliations, uh,
uh, between the various,
among the various, uh,
couples and restitutions made including
restitution to the barber who's based
in, was uh, uh, you, you
haven't gotten there,
but you will see that there is this
their steers of restitutions to all the
characters who have been
injured or damaged in some, uh,
or harmed in some, in
some way. Uh, the, the,
the in becomes like a court of
law where these institutions are,
uh, are made now, uh,
I want to quote, have yet in a
positive light. Now, uh, and,
uh, he, he's,
he's right in the sense that the values
are church changing and there is sort of
an emerging bourgeois sense.
It is true.
He says that neoplatonism associated
with the tradition of course we love was
still the accepted poetic and artistic
Vigo four h four aristocratic sentiment.
But through the influence of Christian
humanism and as an expression of the
strength of the new use,
the bureau can patients with secular
life and above all marriage replaced the
stylized conventions of chivalry and
the austere ideals of monasticism.
This,
this may be true,
particularly if we take into account
all of the economic and legal background
that I have given you about
the relationship between
these characters. The,
the fact that Fernando is, they
say, well, I'm Dong a and a,
and it's not going to inherit a much of a,
of the state,
which makes him very anxious. Uh, uh,
the fact that [inaudible]
runs the farm and, and,
and has money and all of that. Uh,
it does give the impression that,
that there is a kind
of bourgeois sense of,
of marriage and stability
that is replacing the old
ideals of the neoplatonic,
uh, idea of, uh,
contained in this aristocratic versions
of love in the poetic traditions.
The idea, uh, also seems to be that, uh,
to cure the characters in the real world,
uh,
of the fiction where they live,
they also have to be cured in
their dreams and inventions. Uh,
which is one of the overall plot strands
now being resolved in the karate.
He's the only one missing here.
I mean,
everyone is going to be sort of cured
of his or her dreams, hallucinations.
Uh, uh, uh, and so forth. Uh,
but don Quixote still has not,
but they have to be cured of those
hallucinations as well as, uh, uh,
their situation has to,
has to be stabilized in social terms.
The priest,
uh,
the barber and the rest of the characters
engaged don Quixote at his level of
madness in part because they
are also mad in their own ways.
You have to realize, uh, this, uh,
what are the priests and the Barbara
doing traipsing all over Spain after the
night?
Uh,
remember what I said before about the
priest is a very strange priest who's a
reader of romances of chivalry.
Uh,
what has become of the priest duties at
the church or the barbarous customers?
Uh,
we,
we ask they to have left
normal lives as sanctuary has.
He left his wife and children to engage
in an insane quest after an insane man.
The point is that mental life is made
up of levels that mirror and his toward
each other, and the literature
appears to emerge from this interplay.
The creative mind of the author is
capable of reflecting or expressing the
multilayered essence of that
mental life after the captive,
stale about which we'll be talking
in the next, uh, class. Fascinating,
very entertaining. Coptic style based
on said Rhonda for his own life.
The priests and the barber and the
others will send Don Quixote home.
They will cage him and sent him home and
a return that will still engage them in
further, uh, adventures. Uh,
the end of part one is near and
we will get to it next week.